imagine you had the power to take any
shape you want it and we leave any shape
from changing the way you look all the
way the changing into a different
species
the idea of shape-shifting has
fascinated us for centuries ranging from
Greek mythology to the x-men science
fiction right but what if we could pull
it off
how could you get your body to
shape-shift and once you did would you
use your powers for good or evil this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you could shape-shift let's be honest
every single one of us has thought about
shape-shifting what if you could look
like your favorite celebrity what would
it be like to soar through the skies
like a bird what if you could transform
into your deepest desires and greatest
fears
daydreaming aside how could you
reprogram your body into taking on
another form entirely well it's going to
be a little tricky if we look at I'm
Stein's famous equation e equals MC
squared we see that mass and energy are
related so if you want to decrease or
increase in mass you either have to
release energy or absorb it so far so
good right for example let's say you
want to unleash the beast that rages
within you a puppy what you thought you
were going to be able to go full
werewolf on your first try please
so let's say you weigh 60 kilograms and
you want to transform into an adorable
six-month-old golden retriever oh what a
good boy oh you're a good boy a good boy
who weighs in at 20 kilograms well you'd
need to reduce your body mass by 40
kilograms and that's no easy feat if we
use Einstein's equation we see that this
mass loss will generate 860 megatons of
energy for perspective that's
approximately 17 times the amount of
energy released from the largest nuclear
bomb ever detonated the Tsar Bomba so
let's see if we can do this without
killing everyone around you let's borrow
a trick from another member of the
animal kingdom the lizard some lizards
are known to drop their tails when
trying to escape so maybe this could be
one way to reduce your mass one limb at
a time not exactly ideal right and
that's just a one-way trip as a puppy
you would have to store all that energy
somewhere to transform back our advices
carefully before you shape-shift but I'm
still the good boy but let's say you
managed to pull it off and mastered the
skill now the real fun can start think
of all the possibilities you could turn
into anyone or anything well if you want
to take the hero route you could teach
the world your newfound power and you
could realistically end the entire
planets self-esteem issues body image
and low self confidence would be a thing
of the past people could finally be the
person they feel they are inside and all
because of you you know after you rob a
bank
let's be real have you noticed most
characters with shape-shifting abilities
by the bad guys
you could become the ultimate con artist
you could steal the world's fortunes and
never be recognized you could take the
form of a world leader and declare a
world war or you could literally turn
into a monster and terrorize humanity
it's a lot of power with even more
responsibility the good news is we won't
have to deal with this predicament for
quite some time as the ability to
shape-shift hasn't been conquered by
science yet but that doesn't mean we
can't be fooled deep fakes are getting
more and more realistic every day giving
humans the ability to make celebrities
do anything they want it won't be long
until anyone's face can be plastered
onto someone else's body in the meantime
let's focus on a smaller scale of
shape-shifting you can always change
your hair workout or get a new outfit
those aren't superpowers but they're a
start
hey you do you but with all this
shape-shifting talk we can't help but
wonder what it would be like if we had
other superpowers like what if you had
super-strength well that's a story for
another what if
[Music]